new technology at mccarran airport is
making some big changes that impact how
we get through tsa lines victoria saha
shows us what you need to know before
you fly
getting your boarding pass won't have to
be your first priority when you get to
mccarran airport you can go straight to
security that's one less thing the
traveler needs to do and it should make
that process a little bit quicker the
airport installed credential
authentication technology also known as
cat this will be at all security
checkpoints impacting every single
traveler flying out of mccarran this
will allow tsa to scan your photo id and
confirm your flight without you having
to hand over your boarding pass we need
to know
the person who is flying is who they say
they are that they are not an imposter
in any way so the cat unit is able to
detect that just because you don't need
a boarding pass doesn't mean everyone
will be allowed through i'm going to
hand my id over to this officer since i
didn't have a ticket there's no flight
information attached to my name outbound
passengers say they like this method a
lot better they're not having to dig it
in and out of their bags and stuff like
that so just having your id ready is
super super convenient it just went very
fast
all i had to do was just take my mask
down and that was it mccarran airport is
one of the few airports across the
country to implement this technology
victoria saha live local now
the only exception to this are flyers
who are under 18 they don't need to
present an id but they will need to show
their boarding pass